next speaker is Jaime Fernandes it's a
pleasure to have him is a numpy core
developer you know that library that's
behind everything we've seen today and
yesterday so he knows how it works which
is kind of amazing to me so please
welcome
Jaime Fernandez so thanks thanks for
having me
let's see how this goes we're gonna talk
about numpy indexing which is not like
the sexiest of of topics one would think
but well I'll try to make it a little
bit interesting before before we start
just do a show hence how many of you are
numpy users ok cool that's there it'd be
all of you you're with me up one more
minute how many of you know what fun
scene mixing is okay know that many and
I suppose that then if I ask you about
orthogonal indexing they're probably no
one that that knows what it is it's good
I mean you you'll at least know that
they exist by the end by the end of of
today so I did a very early version of
this talk about a year ago to the San
Diego Python users group and we did the
same show hands and in a room full of
about 50 people I think there were two
hands raised and well it was an
interesting experience but I lost them
really really sort of like five minutes
into the thing was mostly blank stares
into the into the void but well we we
went through it you should do better I'm
hoping that that you you'll get lost a
little later if you do now the thing is
there were a lot of people yesterday
saying that what they're doing is not
rocket science or now this is not that
hard this is some quite difficult and
confusing [ __ ]
quite honestly and it takes a lot of
banging your head against it until it
starts making sense so if if you don't
understand how something works or or if
you're confused it's normal we won't
come through that and it it gets better
with time that's that's the most I can I
can promise so as I was saying there's
like - there's fancy indexing there's
orthogonal indexing fancy indexing is
the way that numpy does
multi-dimensional indexing and then
orthogonal indexing is the way that just
about every other library out there that
has to index multi-dimensional arrays
that's what they use
right so it's numpy and everything else
and everything else is typically newer
and more modern right so it sort of
gives the the idea that maybe numpy is
like the the ball guy with a ponytail at
the disco right that's still going hard
twenty years as if he should have left
and maybe it's time to say well I mean
we're wrong and we should we should you
know do follow follow the the trend that
everyone else is following the
interesting thing is that at least some
of those libraries that implement
orthogonal indexing are built on top of
numpy and they use fancy indexing to
implement orthogonal indexing right so
there may be maybe there is a case there
for hey really fancy indexing is a
superset of orthogonal indexing so it's
cool to have more functionality even if
it's at the expense of of some
complexity right so and I'm gonna try to
sort of defend that stand but I think
I'm gonna fail at it and you'll see why
so well that will we'll get don't let me
get ahead ahead of myself
what does make sense if you have several
libraries implementing a functionality
that depends on an anti functionality is
to try to push that functionality
upstream you don't want to have six
different implementations of the same
thing that start diverging slowly one
from the other and makes things more
confusing to two users that find that
these libraries that does this yes
that tiny slightly different way that's
bad enough to to throw your or your your
understanding of how the whole ecosystem
together all so about a year ago there
was this discussion that started in in
Nampa world about how should we make
access to this orthogonal indexing
whatever that may be and you'll find out
soon enough available to two other
packages and actually how do we
implement it in NAMM try and make it
available and we were having this very
boring discussion on well you know do it
like these but but that it was mostly
boring I mean it was like a completely
uninteresting unless you're really
involved with this discussion and all of
a sudden it turned into an I know it was
like evolved with torches going to the
castle to kill the monster in the movies
it was like I mean they the rate that
the hate that people had for fancy
indexing that that sort of popped out of
nowhere was for me it was a big surprise
because I'm a big fan of the thing I'll
admit that but but yeah fortunately we
we call things down
I learned a thing or two about the the
social dynamics of open-source
communities there were other do that
comes of that I think we reacted pretty
quickly to to that realization of how
upset people were worried about fancy
indexing I'm echoing right stand back
and I think that we've seen a day or two
of that first outburst of Rage we had
like actually I wrote it we had like a
canonical Python mock-up of what would
orthogonal indexing look in in Nampa and
not more than two months later there was
like a proper C implementation there's
an F an anti enhancement proposal
outlining how and why that should be
done but the thing is that a year later
nothing else has happened we have this
outburst of rate we have this outburst
of coding and then everything has has
quieted down and no one is like talking
anymore about this so one of the main
reasons that I'm here talking to you is
because we want to hear from users right
we are like
some large community that participated
actively and and there's a strong
sensation that we may be missing what
people out there really are using things
for so if any of what I tell you today
resonates with your experiences if
there's something you hate something you
like something you are indifferent about
find some time find me anywhere during
the rest of the day
I'll leave my contact with Oh somewhere
yeah but I mostly the main reason for
this aside from educating you and
getting a free pass to the conference is
to to get feedback from from users okay
so yeah with with that out of the way
what I would like to do is to walk you
through how how indexing works right and
and from the background that I've told
you it's not going to be a very good
trip for fancy indexing I mean we're
gonna talk a lot of a lot of [ __ ] about
the dates mostly going to focus on the
on the bad parts right but because
that's going to be the the the center of
the talk before we do that I would like
to also highlight some of the nicest
things of a fancy indexing I'm very
partial to this because four years ago I
didn't know that numpy existed right and
of all the things in the world that can
make someone fall in love with a library
it was fun seeing the same fans in the
team what caught my eye in in Nampa
right so there's a bunch of imports I'm
using Python 3.5 because if you use
Python 2.7 they look bad at you at these
conferences because we should all be
switching to three but yeah behind the
closed door of my of my house I use 2.7
a little bit that I'm I'm using a
development version of non 5 I can give
you a link to the pull request that this
is built from I doubt that anyone is
going to go through through that trouble
but this is basically the pull request
that implements the new the future of
numpy indexing right
so we'll see some things that you will
not see with your stock you just use
anaconda as I'm doing here and you use
numpy I think at one point then that's
publicly available now you will not get
some of the same results or you will not
be able to see some of the things that
I'm gonna do here but yeah that's that
and see they've given me a stage I'm
gonna show you a picture of my daughter
it is coming this is about ten million
pixels it's black and white because it's
easier and it's also trendy R and we're
going to transform this is this image at
the time that I was when I fell in love
with numpy I knew I was working for
hewlett-packard we were doing printers
and there's a lot of image processing
there and one thing we did a lot was to
what we call linearize an image which
basically means that you have your your
colors the wrong your yeah your each
pixel has a value that ranges from 0 to
255 that it's supposed to represent
colorfulness or or darkness in this case
right but when you're going to print it
you want to turn that into how much in
you have to put down there and
colourfulness and amount of things are
related but it's not a linear
relationship and if you don't modify
that what you get printed is not what
you what you were seeing in the screen
so you have to apply a nonlinear
transformation to the to the input
values to get something else so
typically in image processing if you do
that with a lookup table okay basically
you because typically images are encoded
as as unsigned byte you have 256
possible values so you create yourself
an array of 256 values this basically
says that well this is transforming the
first what 1012 levels to zero okay
but yeah it's basically an array of 256
integral values and this is easier to
see if we put it
we're basically modifying things so that
light dark colors are going to look
darker and light colors are going to
look lighter okay yes this sort of burnt
look to an image if you wanted to do
this in Python you would typically do
something like this and here right
you basically iterate over the rows and
the columns of the image for every pixel
in the image you extract the value you
look it up in the lookup table and then
you write it to your output file and you
keep doing that 9 million times 10
million times depending on the size of
your image right I was afraid of doing
this let's see how it works
let's time how about long does it take
and we're probably gonna have an
uncomfortable silence before it finishes
come on
it should take about three seconds to
process that image which turns out to
twelve or something like that here yeah
3 3 36 now numpy lets you do this in a
blink of the eye by basically saying
well yeah down here saying let me take
care of iteration for you you're gonna
iterate over all the pixels just throw
the image inside the the square brackets
which is the indexing operation and I'll
take care of that we have the lookup
table we have the image and the same
thing happens 200 times faster if I'm
not mistaken come on yeah 15 3.36 it's
basically 200 times faster and it's a
single line of code and before I
discovered this I was living in a world
of C++ libraries wrapped in sweet and
then you could use them in Python but it
was it was bad I mean no it and and this
was like it open
my eyes and my life to a whole new set
of I don't know of experiences that I
have never imagined right yes to see how
this works
so we basically ruined the picture but
it that's what we asked it to do so so
we should be we should be happy looks
yeah it's it's [ __ ] but the lights are
lighter and the darks are darker so so
mission accomplished right and okay so
you've you've seen pictures Victor
Victor Tehran of PyCon Spain fame he
says that when you give a talk you
should try to be entertaining and catch
the and well I hope we've basically done
that's all the entertainment you're
gonna get today that's what I wanted to
make clear now now it's gonna get boring
but you've you've been entertained so so
keep that in the back of your minds yeah
so we're gonna walk very quickly about
how in the team works mostly and we're
going to do it by by dimensionality of
the array being indexed because it makes
it easier to progress and see where
things start going bad and when they
derail completely right so we're gonna
get a an array full of letters right
it's just the alphabet numpy
one-dimensional arrays are really very
similar to two Python lists right so if
you index them with a single integer you
of course get the value at that position
J is the tenth letter of the alphabet so
if we index with nine we get the tenth
letter you can also index with slices
and you get what you would expect
everything starting at the third letter
and then every third letter there's no
big surprises here we could go on to how
slicing an umpire array gives you up you
and not a copy but I'm not gonna go
there there's slight differences but
it's not not very relevant and the
interesting thing is that you can also
use an array to index an array right and
when you do this it basically lets you
grab completely
the arbitrary slice and in this case how
cute it fancy anything using hi fighting
how how could you not love it
right all those mean people have want to
get rid of it should be ashamed of
themselves right and so we're gonna go
see how it works into the erase but I
haven't really explained I mean the
first example I showed you was an image
no it was a one-dimensional array being
indexed by a two dimensional array but
it should fall here and there indexing
1d arrays and we are tiptoeing over it
right why not right I'm sure that
there's a good reason for it and that
nothing bad will happen by not fully
explaining that that case let's go to to
the erase to find out if that's true
once more this is really a a Python
explanation this is a very stupid class
that simply shows you what you're using
to index that class I just print what
gets bad pass to the get item magic
function as you could imagine if you
pass a single value what you get inside
the function is that value a Python has
and this is not just about indexing but
when you start putting commas in places
where they don't belong python typically
wraps that in a couple okay so this kind
of quirk of of python is what Nampa uses
to index multi-dimensional arrays when
you index a multi-dimensional array
numpy is expecting to have one index per
dimension and there are ways around it
we'll see that very quickly but
basically rather than using square
bracket square bracket square bracket
square bracket as you would do with
lists of lists of lists you put
everything inside commas inside the
single square bracket separated by
commas if you do the math you're
actually not saving any typing so you're
you're changing a comma and a space by a
closing and opening bracket so there's
really no no saving anything there are
other reasons I mean and it basically
looks prettier right which is probably
good enough of a reason but yeah let's
let's see how numpy am those two
dimensional indexes we're still going
with with letters I've added number so
that it fits into our into a nice square
array and yeah not many surprises if you
use two integrals to to index that array
you get the value at the fourth row
fifth column that one here in this right
when you use a slice and an integral
what
then let's let's look see what it gives
you here it says well it gives you the
contents of the third row and from that
third row it gives you every second
column right if you do not if there are
missing indices it replaces them by full
slices okay so yeah if you have less
listen this is done dimensions in the
array you get basically more than that
instead of every second you get all of
them okay
you can do the same thing with the
column now here there is an interesting
point in that that up there is not a row
vector and this is not a column vector
they are one dimensional arrays that
have the content of that column and row
vector okay but this is not you've lost
the dimensionality when you use a as
color to index one dimension that that
dimension is going from the output okay
and this is important and if instead of
a slice you use an array the result is
basically the same you're getting for
that row those items for that column
those items okay yeah there are the same
results with slices or or arrays and
there is then the case of what happens
when you mix you get rid of colors and
you mix slices with slices and this is
basically what you get is
this rose these problems and we get the
intersection this is what orthogonal
indexing is okay if each index is acting
on it it's kind of a big name for a
small thing they also told it some
people call it outer indexing but anyway
that's all there is there's a lot of of
professors working on numpy and they
seem to like the the big world right so
anyway
two slices do this if you use a slice
and an array the behavior is the same
okay if you use an array and a slice the
behavior is the same so of course if you
use two arrays you get something
entirely different because why not this
oh that should be actually red like the
red because that's a worm and that's a
warning that you only get if you use
this pull request because basically an
umpire is telling you you're gonna hurt
yourself don't do this right and we will
explain what that means but yeah that's
the reason to use letters for the array
so I could say right why the [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] without explicitly spelling it
out what numpy is doing here is it's
using those those indices to get rows
and columns but instead of getting all
the rows and all the columns it's
combining them to get a specific item
inside the array right so if you look at
this like if you wink at it what you're
saying is like really that behavior we
saw at the very beginning where the the
shape of the indexing array determines
the shape of the output I had a one
dimensional array that I index with a
two dimensional array and the result was
a two dimensional image transform is not
a small thing that only happens for one
the one dimensional images that's like
the core thing of a fancy indexing you
get the same thing as the array are
using to index and
actually both arrays have to have the
same shape they have to be have the same
the same size the same dimensions
because if not they cannot work together
and of course that means that if what I
want to get is a two dimensional output
all I need to do is use two
two-dimensional impulse right so if I do
twice the typing with the same warning I
can get the orthogonal indexing like
output right this is hard to to try
trying to convince someone that see
orthogonal indexing is a subset of fancy
indexing you guys have to do a little
more typing it doesn't really work out
very well I mean people get angry when
you when you try to to say that it's
actually it's actually easier and we
have to go into another of those obscure
features of numpy that turn out to be
super powerful
that's called broadcasting and first I'm
gonna show you that with a clever use of
square brackets I can actually get the
same output with much less typing right
and what's what's going on here so
basically what we're doing is we're
using an array that's actually a two
dimensional array to index the rows it's
like a a column vector and we're using
an array that's actually a two
dimensional array you might want to come
to square brackets there's two of them
so this is actually a row vector if we
put their shapes together one has two
rows on one column the other has one row
on three columns when you give numpy
arrays that have different shapes and
it's expected to do things with them
together it tries to broadcast them what
broadcasting means is that if one
dimension is a one it will match any
other dimension basically that single
row or that single column will be
replicated until it fit three columns
okay and similarly for this that single
row will be replicated until it fills
two rows so
with only one dimension for it you can
create a two-dimensional array and the
interesting thing is that you don't
actually create it you numpy has ways to
access the memory the small memory you
have so that it looks like it to
dimensional array without you having to
actually allocate that that information
so when we get those two arrays that we
have defined that is one one column and
one row together we get what we've
already seen which is that aside from a
warning you're gonna hurt yourself and
do this you get the two-dimensional
output that you were looking for this is
so so typical that I haven't modified
this like it should that there is a
function numpy IX underscore that does
this for you you give it to several
one-dimensional arrays and it adds extra
dimensions that they will broadcast
together and do orthogonal indexing
right and if you use these inside
indexing you get the orthogonal indexing
like resolve you were you were expecting
so this sort of kind of says yeah yeah I
mean you can do orthogonal indexing with
fancy indexing it's it's a little
annoying right you have to type a little
bit more but but it's sort of there
right if if this is all the annoyance
that that fancy indexing was causing
people it will probably be this basis
though you don't understand how good it
is so you don't deserve all the good
work we've done for you and go away but
unfortunately it doesn't stop stop here
and like before we had not fully
explained how does the two-dimensional
thing worked here we have tiptoed about
the fact that when we were using a slice
and an array to index
working beautifully well we were having
no problem there and and again I'm gonna
ignore that we no one asked so you
probably have it all figured out already
and let's move on to 3d arrays so we
have a three dimensional arrays I'm not
gonna we're not going to look at the at
the actual outputs because it gets
really confusing we'll just look at the
shape of the output now and basically we
have three three planes of four rows and
five columns it's okay for full of
numbers there they're mostly irrelevant
and so there's there's 27 if you you
have in slices and arrays there's 27
possible combinations that we could look
at for a three dimensional array we're
gonna choose the the fun one where it
all goes all goes crazy and yeah this is
like a bad joke a slice an end run or a
walk into a bar
you won't believe what happened next so
I'm gonna walk you through a few of
these and eventually they'll probably
make sense so we have a slice in the
first dimension so we should get three
items on that dimension we have a scalar
on the second one so that dimension
disappears and we have a two item array
in the last dimension so one would think
that you would get three items in the
first dimension one gone too and the
shape is 3-2 as expected if you reverse
the position of the scholar and the
array you're still having a slice of
three items and an array of two you'll
get different results but you should
still get a shape of 3-2 and you do if
we move the slice to the end now we're
getting rid of the first dimension we
have two dimensions index in the second
the slice in the last which had five
items so we're expecting a shape of 2/5
and we get that again if we reverse the
position of this color on the array it's
still two in the first five in the last
so we get to five if we put the slice
between the scholar and the array we
would think that there's two from the
first a full slice in the middle the
last is bone so this should be 2 4 2 4
yes right and we do so of course when we
get to the last example where we with
would rightfully think that the first
dimension is go done we'll get three
items from the second one and two from
the last we will get at an output of
three two and of course we don't
actually it should have been for two not
not three two and we get the opposite
and a warning you're gonna hurt yourself
don't do this right what's what's
happening here and and the the thing is
you have to keep in mind that this has
to be a general functionality that works
for up to thirty two dimensional arrays
with index with whatever crazy
combination of slices arrays or integers
you throw at it so I'm gonna show you
with an example and slightly more
complicated example how this works and
you might recognize those words from
from import this in the face of ability
we will see why this applies here I'm
gonna use to to erase the same to erase
I think as before to index our our our
three dimensional array and they have a
two three shape together okay so
somewhere in our output we're running
out of time you're gonna have two and
three close to each other so the
question is what happens if I have those
two arrays separated from each other and
I do the slice in the middle we know
that I 1 and I 2 together will create a
three shape but there's also a force
coming from the slice in the middle and
the question is well where do we place
that that slice in the whole shape and
really the only sensible answer is put
it at the end you could be tempted to
say no no no no no there's there's only
two I mean it should go between the two
right because one is had a indexing the
first the other is index in the last it
clearly goes in the middle you might
expect that the output of this would be
243 but what happens if you're indexing
two dimensions with a three-dimensional
array so if those this if the shape of
the broadcast of our two dimensions is
two three five we're gonna have two
three and five and we also have a fourth
where do we put the four right there's
no longer it's no longer clear that it
should go between the two numbers the
only sensible thing is to it always put
it at the back or always put it at the
front and the the convention is that
slice dimensions go at the end they're
actually called the subspace right fancy
big words for normal things no and this
is a perfectly good rational behavior
that it's a convention get used to it
and I move on with the rest of your life
but someone got clever and at some point
decided wait wait wait wait wait if the
slice is at the front we don't want to
send the slice to the back we know that
we have to have two three and five
together but the slices at the front
let's not put the four at the back so
there's a quirk in here where rather
than having that three sent to the end
we put it at the beginning because all
the slices are together and all the
arrays are at the back and this is this
is very convenient because this is what
makes those cases of a slice and an
array work but this is what [ __ ]
everyone else right because it starts
being surprising because we are deciding
that we want to guess what the
user ones right we don't give you a set
of rules and we say hey this is how it
works
learn it use them we decide to figure
out for you what you want and when you
get it wrong hell breaks loose okay so
this and mostly yes this is what we are
willing to agree that is broken in numpy
indexing right how do we want to solve
it and this is pull requests 6075 has
the answer to all things we have added
or this pull request adds three indexers
to numpy erase and this is basically I
think it's stolen from pandas pandas has
a couple of indexers that led you index
with numbers instead of labels or or
something like that
the Oh V and L stands for outer
orthogonal vector eyes which is the way
that we call fancy and legacy which is
this broken mess that it's our default
indexing so if this ever gets merged
let's just remember that our array has
three four five as dimensions you could
index the orthogonal indexer with two
arrays that don't match that hey two
dimensions from the first three from the
middle three from the from the end you
get the expected output of four from the
middle not three from the middle of two
four three no surprises here you can
have back Erised indexing where despite
having the slice at the front the slice
of three gets moved to the end because
in vectorized indexing we put the the
the subspace this life dimensions at the
end and we first put the two that is the
result from broadcasting those two
indexing arrays I'm overtime and we have
legacy legacy indexing which is well I
mean enjoy enjoy your world of pain
right like we're going to mix things
around and
yeah and I'm out of time and out of
cells in my notebook so that's all I
have to say about numpy indexing thank
you very much
6000 pulled requests that's quite a lot
and growing there's there's a thousand
open issues which is so questions
everyone understood everything it's
great so I have a more general question
about numpy since all we use numpy in
some way or another and you get to see
some of those pull requests and how the
gate repository is working how healthy
you think that number is now since we
all depend on number can you turn off
the recording no it's it's okay
mostly I mean there's there's things
like this that that are interesting
because when they happen and someone
comes saying oh this is moving to the
other way around
the other side of and then everyone will
think oh it's a bug it's a bug it's a
bike and there's there's a part of you
thinking it has to be a bike because
this is really weird
and there's also the part of you saying
I mean people don't understand indexing
I'm supposed to do even though I don't
so it's probably yes than other idiot
whining about things he doesn't
understand and then eventually you find
oh no no no hear its intended behavior
you see you're wrong we're right but
mostly it works it has little things I
mean there's there's open issues from
6-7 years ago with segmentation faults
happening when you do which those are
supposed to be really really bad that no
one has solved them ever so but mostly
it's okay I mean there's there's dark
corners that you shouldn't go to or you
hurt your
self and we're trying to to at least
signpost them so you don't hurt yourself
but it's mostly okay I mean it's and
it's getting better I think
there's there's quite a healthy
contribution pool of contributors now so
I I think it looks okay sometimes when
people asks me because I have been
coding in math in a sorry in in Nampa
with nap I so for a lot for some time
also in using Python for science when
people asked me how much the whole
ecosystem has improved and partly thanks
to number I saw that we really have to
think of all your effort I tend to use
the dye used na Marais oh yeah and and I
mean a lot of the of the weirdness in
Nampa comes from the fact that there's
there something that I mean even I have
I have yeah so there's a very very very
strong and strict policy about backward
compatibility in Nampa there's a lot of
things that are broken I mean it's like
like here indexing is is clearly broken
it it's contra people if you try to do
elaborate things we're gonna pull our
leg in the middle and make you fall over
so the reasonable thing to do it would
be like solve this get get rid of
indexing but you cannot do that because
there's always someone that has made
this part of their workflow
there's the xkcd comic out there about
the guy that used that when you put
someone solves an issue we're hitting
the spacebar heats up the CPU and the
guys saying no no but that's part of
what I use so that to turn caps on
because I have a temperature sensor on
my keyboard right and you simply cannot
there's lots of things that are broken
that you know it that you should fix
them but it's like we can't because
there's this guy that wrote code 15
years ago or maybe not that that long
ago and that depends on it and you can't
simply break it so it's keeping the
balance between making it go forward and
and not hurting anyone from the past is
it it's a difficult thing but I mean
it's fun though
I guess thanks for speaker again